[Music]
a roman bishop sits in the window of his
episcopal home
on the north african coast it is late
afternoon
he looks out at the sun setting over the
mediterranean
and watches the waves break along the
shore sand
piling into disordered heaps when the
sun sets
it will be time to light the lamps if he
wants to continue his work
he is augustine of hippo theologian
philosopher and saint famed for his five
million words of writing
that have survived to the modern age he
longs for the golden light to remain
for time to pause or even run backwards
what might that look like
he considers the sun would rise from the
horizon not so different to the glory of
a dawn
but all else would seem very strange the
waves crashing on the beach must collect
and assemble themselves in the most
unnatural fashion
with water droplets rising towards one
another into a teetering pile
before retreating back out to sea it
seems to violate the lord's natural
order
and augustine shies away from the
discomforting thought
what then if he could witness time laid
out before him
moving forward inexorably from one
moment
to the next the waves would crash
unceasingly on the shore advancing on
the bustling town until it reduced his
home to little more than a heap of
rubble and sand
as his quill drips ink onto the
parchment augustine's mind
wanders to see time itself advancing
ruining all in its path spreading its
relentless chaos
the present world of man crumbles to
meaningless piles
the thriving natural world eventually
decays to nothing more than dust in the
wind
and in the sky stars wink out one by one
until there is nothing left by which to
measure the passing moments
with nothing more for time to devour
would this finally be the end of the
voracious beast itself
what then is time if not the inevitable
march of disorder the inevitable
destruction of god's structured universe
into nothing more
than an eternal pile of sand
shaking himself from the darkness of his
waking dream augustine finds it truly is
darkening outside
with the last glimmers of the setting
sun he breathes deeply
and scratches out his final words for
the day
what then is time
but had augustine really been able to
see into the future
and probe the minds of modern scholars
he would have seen that his dark
imaginings
were not only accurate but substantiated
by the highest theoretical physics and
cosmology
the hungry beast of time powered by
ever-growing entropy
is unstoppable and relentless it is
driven not by some demon bent on
destruction but by the unassailable
forces of mathematics
that have gripped the cosmos from its
first moments to its inevitable end
this entropy bound up in the mathematics
of particles and energy powers the arrow
of time
forcing our eyes forward into a future
that is unavoidable as it
is disturbing and the past that is
forever
just out of reach
[Music]
some one and a half millennia after
saint augustine found his words lacking
on the subject of time the industrial
english city of manchester
was preparing to manipulate it in the
early 19th century
timekeeping clocks were calibrated
against local sundials
giving rise to times that could differ
by as much as 30 minutes
between the west and east coasts of
england
but with the advent of the industrial
revolution and the spread of the railway
network
the country suddenly needed a unified
system
now the difference of a few minutes
between london and other stations on the
network could mean passengers missing
their trains or even
collisions on intersecting tracks and so
it was decided that for the first time
in history
time itself would be changed
in january 1846 the residents of
manchester
collectively traveled through time
jumping 13 minutes
in an instant as the town's clocks were
adjusted to match the standard time set
by the royal observatory
in greenwich london
although time had been measured for
millennia following the passage of the
sun across the sky
this was the first time it had been
standardized
thanks to the incessant march of
industry but in truth
this so-called standard time is
arbitrary
little more than an imaginary structure
for our busy lives
the sun still sets in manchester 13
minutes later than in london
regardless of the time on the clocks
and yet the steam-powered locomotives of
the industrial revolution
did open our minds to the nature
of time in an altogether
unexpected way
some 20 years before england's clock
spent to the unstoppable force of the
railway
efforts to understand the heat engines
that powered these mechanical
juggernauts led french engineer and
physicist
sadie carneau to make a prophetic
observation
steam engines had been quickly adopted
across the rapidly industrializing world
bringing success and riches to all who
embraced them
but little work had been done to
understand how they really worked
this was the concern of carnot when in
1824
he penned his influential reflections on
the motive power
of fire his observation which may seem
simple and obvious now
was that heat always flows from a warmer
body
to a colder one this explains how a
fireplace can warm a cold room
why ice cubes melt when they're left in
the sun and why molten newly formed
planets solidify and cool in the cold
vacuum of space
it is an irreversible natural process
and it is this
that provides the motive power in all
heat engines
in this carno laid the foundation for
the theory
that was to become the second law of
thermodynamics
this law was developed over the
following century until it was brought
in line with our evolving physical
frameworks
now we recognize that not just heat
but all systems move in a single
direction
one that will decrease the free energy
of that system
today we describe this change in terms
of entropy
a mathematical way of measuring the
amount of disorder within a system
specifically it measures the number of
possible ways that a large-scale
macroscopic structure can be created
from its microscopic components
a train locomotive is a highly ordered
structure there are very few ways of
arranging all the component parts to
create a functioning engine
and so we say that it's entropy it's
measure of disorder is low
a heap of wreckage in a railway
scrapyard may have the same components
as the locomotive
but piled on top of one another in a
disordered heap there are many ways of
arranging the scrap to make the same
chaotic pile
because of these many possibilities its
entropy
is by definition high what's more
entropy always tends to increase
a functioning train locomotive if left
for long enough will always become a
disordered pile of wreckage
the chances that a heap of engine
components will spontaneously group
together and assemble into a fully
functioning train
are infinitesimally small entropy
always increases everything
tends towards disorder so when coal
burns in the locomotive engine
it changes irreversibly from a
structured lump of energy rich carbon
to a disordered pile of inert ash
while its free energy is dissipated into
the engine's boiler
as heat this fundamental property of our
universe is not
only the reason for steam power's
success but also
the basis for all of time itself
this unstoppable change in entropy in
everything around us
provides us with a way of distinguishing
one moment
from the next
it was just past dawn when arthur
eddington began walking home through the
streets of cambridge
he'd spent the night peering up at the
stars from the university's observatory
and his head was still filled with
wheeling points of light as he tried to
make sense of their celestial motions
suddenly he was pulled sharply out of
his musing not far from the door to his
apartment
as a stern-faced woman resolutely
blocked his path
she held out a white feather its soft
downy barbs catching in the morning
breeze
[Music]
he knew better than to resist taking the
feather
he smiled politely and neatly
sidestepped her
moments later just inside his home
eddington shook off his coat
hung up his hat and added the feather to
the growing pile
on the mantelpiece it was 1917
and arthur eddington was a quaker and a
pacifist
according to society that made him a
coward
but eddington was no coward when it came
to grappling with the mysteries
of the cosmos he became a world leader
in gravity and relativity
in 1928 he wrote an ambitious book that
made the concept of entropy
accessible to the layman for the first
time in it he asked the reader to
imagine the universal increase in
entropy
as an arrow which can only ever point
from order
to disorder from the past to the future
in this he laid the foundation for the
arrow of time
defined by the directional change in
entropy from one moment to the next
as time moves forward things become more
disordered and the passage of time is
represented by this inescapable growth
in cosmological chaos the arrow of time
thus describes why time must always
move forward why cause must proceed
effect
and why we can only ever experience it
in that way
time travel has become an immensely
popular trope in science fiction
bending our minds with the paradoxes it
creates
to travel backward in time one must
experience the universe in the
unsettling improbability of decreasing
entropy
of things spontaneously becoming more
ordered
waves uncrashing on a beach and backing
away from shore
and heaps of wreckage self-assembling
into functioning engines
not only does it seem unnatural but it
violates the arrow of time that rules
the universe and our own experiences
even if one travels instantaneously
backwards and then continues to
experience
time forwards from a point in the past
it becomes
impossible to define a consistent
universal
arrow of time
theoretically if we could find a way to
travel faster than the speed of light
then through the mind-bending
relationship between space and time we
would also be moving backwards in time
so says the mathematics at least but the
reality is quite different
the speed of light is one of the most
reliable unassailable constants in the
universe today
when we travel at the speed of light
einstein's equations of relativity
tell us that our mass rises to infinity
while our size
shrinks to zero surpassing that breaks
every law of physics we know of
not only that but by jetting into space
faster than light
and backwards in time we would arrive at
our destination
before we had departed we become trapped
in a causal
loop isolated from the normal universe
where
thanks to the arrow of time a cause must
always
precede the effect
[Music]
stephen hawking was so certain that
reverse time travel would not be
possible
that he held a party on the 28th of june
2009
for which he only issued invitations the
following day
the only way a guest could attend was if
they traveled backward
in time nobody made it and hawking was
left alone
with 10 bottles of champagne
traveling forward in time is another
matter it's easy
we do it all the time experiencing one
second of the universe for every second
of our lives
we can even do it at an accelerated pace
if we stray too close to a black hole
and are gripped by the space-time
altering forces of its enormous gravity
skirting close to the event horizon of a
rotating black hole about eight times as
massive as our sun
we can zoom forwards in time sixty
thousand times
faster than our companions on earth we
can jump forward
17 earth hours in a single second
of our own lives the arrow of time
dictates only the direction
not the speeds that one may travel
this directionality sometimes called
non-symmetricality of time
is an oddity that sits in contrast to
most other physical laws within our
cosmos
for example gravitational attraction
looks the same wherever
or whenever you happen to observe it and
two particles in a gas behave
almost like solid steel balls conserving
their energy and speed as they collide
and rebound
these collisions would look the same
whether played forward or in reverse
thus the arrow of time does not result
from the movements of individual
particles
as these are governed exclusively by the
symmetrical laws of physics
the increase in entropy and the passage
of time
is not an inevitable consequence of our
known physical laws
but it is an inescapable feature of the
universe we inhabit
reconciling these two facts remains one
of the great unanswered problems in
physics
some have even suggested that the very
existence of time
is an illusion a consequence of our
inability to perceive the world in all
its detail
[Music]
in the early 19th century french
philosopher and physicist pierre simone
laplace
contemplated the existence of an
omnipotent
individual a veritable demon who could
know the precise position and momentum
of every atom within the universe and
thereby
calculate the nature of the cosmos for
any point
in the future or past could laplace's
all-knowing demon ever really exist
the symmetrical natural laws of the
universe suggest yes
but entropy and time suggest otherwise
the irreversibility of time created by
the dissipation of energy and the
increase in disorder within a system
makes it impossible to make such rigid
predictions about the past
or the future what's more
on the tiniest scale the universe is
ruled by quantum mechanics
whose central tenet is one of
uncertainty and fluctuation
quantum uncertainty means it is
impossible for us to simultaneously know
the position
and speed of a single atom let alone all
of the atoms in the universe
if we could then the entropic measure of
disorder would cease to have
any meaning entropy itself would not
exist
and neither would time but
this doesn't address the question of why
there is asymmetry
in the first place modern scientists
have suggested that our ability to draw
the arrow of time
is a result of our relative proximity to
the big
bang just as the concepts of up and down
only have any meaning when close to the
surface of the earth so it is
our nearness cosmologically speaking to
the beginning of the universe
that allows us to orient ourselves in
time
if that is the case then the big bang
must have represented a moment of
extreme conditions
from which the universe is still winding
down
nearly 14 billion years later
[Music]
ludwig boltzmann never stayed in one
place for very long
throughout the late 19th century he
moved from post to post
in vienna in gratz in austria in
heidelberg in germany
and in berlin in this boltzmann's
personality mirrored the behavior of the
atoms that he studied
always moving never ceasing filled with
unpredictable energy
that could fling him in one direction or
the next from exalted joy
to suicidal depression yet his mood
swings did little to dull his scientific
further
he was a pioneer ahead of his time in
his atomic vision of the world
developing an entirely new field of
science statistical
mechanics with this he created a
framework to understand the unceasing
growth of entropy
for the first time
[Music]
simplistically he imagined colliding
particles as balls
on a billiard table the physics and
geometry of the collisions are
predictable
providing you know the speed and angle
of impact and the usual natural laws
apply
but the more collisions there are one
after the other the more disordered the
table becomes
it becomes increasingly unlikely that
the continuing collisions will result in
an ordered pattern
not impossible but spectacularly
unlikely it might happen once but to
travel against the flow of time
is asking it to keep happening and is
against
all the odds he argued that the second
law of thermodynamics and by extension
the arrow of time
was a statistical necessity a result of
the fact that disordered states are much
more likely than ordered ones
even in a world governed by uncaring
symmetrical
natural laws tragically under a barrage
of criticism for his mathematical
treatment of existence
he committed suicide before his theories
could be proved correct
today if we visualize the universe as an
infinite billiard table
then the ever-growing entropy that
defines the arrow of time shows that we
are still within sight
of the beginning of the game the
universe must have begun with a higher
degree of order if we are still
statistically approaching randomness
but based on what we know about the
earliest moments of the cosmos
this seems counterintuitive a homogenous
soup of protons and raw
energy at first glance seem much more
random and disordered than the
stars galaxies and humans that exist
today
how could a uniform universe have lower
entropy
than the organized one of the present it
is in fact
possible to calculate the entropy of the
early and modern universe
using the so-called boltzmann constant
at the big bang the entropy of the
compressed radiation-filled baby
universe
was by no means low it was 10 to the
power 88 times the boltzmann constant
a 1 followed by 88 zeros
in contrast the entropy of the universe
today
is a 1 followed by 103 zeros
some quadrillion times higher so the
entropy of the universe
has indeed increased but the starting
point
was not as low as we might imagine
it turns out that the order that we
humans are so attuned to
actually has very little impact on the
overall entropy of the universe
and 14 billion years of time has barely
changed the entropy of the background
radiation that's been there since the
beginning
entropy has increased by a factor of a
quadrillion
because of the addition of one
particular structure
black holes
these mysterious objects that reside at
the center of galaxies and which are
lurking darkly elsewhere throughout
space
are the result of vast amounts of matter
being packed into a small space
they contain so much matter so many
particles
that there are almost limitless ways
those particles can be arranged
to still create the same massive
lightless hole in space
this alone is enough to make a
significant impact on the entropy of the
entire universe
the black hole at the center of the
milky way galaxy alone
has entropy that is a thousand times
greater than the entire universe just
after the big bang
with time natural physical laws of
gravity will drive the creation of more
black holes and cause existing ones to
grow
driving the entropy of the cosmos ever
higher and driving time's arrow forward
relentlessly but not
as you may think forever
[Music]
the heat death of the universe will see
all energy evenly distributed across
near infinite space for now
entropy continues to increase inside
black holes and the disorder of the
universe as a whole gradually grows as
time's arrow flies ever forward
but one day trillions of years from now
black holes will have swallowed every
last particle in the cosmos
and they themselves will have evaporated
away
nothing can survive this inevitable end
when all energy and matter is no more
overall entropy will be as large as it
is possible to be
a white noise of randomness in ultimate
equilibrium
and since time cannot flow backwards it
will stay that way
forever without any change
time ceases to have meaning this
truly is the end for time
a cold black empty universe
existing outside of time and space as we
understand it
but it would be wrong to assume that
nothing happens in this empty universe
entropy might have reached its maximum
value but that only means that there are
a near infinite number of ways that the
universe
can be arranged the physical stuff of
the universe can fluctuate
through these random permutations and so
the entropic
equilibrium is a dynamic one
the universe as a whole may not become
any more ordered
but statistics suggest that small
fluctuations could create pockets of
organization
at random when tossing a hundred coins
it's extremely unlikely that all will
show tales
but it's not impossible and since this
most
random universe at the end of its life
is effectively eternal
there is plenty of opportunity for
random tosses
to give any result you can imagine
modern physicist sean carroll has used
this principle to write a potential
origin story for our own cosmos
suppose a universe has lived its life
and met its entropic end
many billions of years ago the result
would be an unchanging
timeless parent universe with random
local fluctuations in entropy
one of these fluctuations might just
configure its energy in such a ways to
create a highly compressed pocket with
inexplicably low entropy
a baby universe with the billiard balls
figuratively set ready for the first
break
this carol argues could be the beginning
of our big bang
and the beginning of our arrow of time
created as a hiccup from a timeless
parent
[Music]
the idea seems compelling and seems to
fit neatly with some cyclical origin
stories
but it also raises a strange and
disturbing possibility
an aged parent cosmos that can create an
entirely new baby universe
can also use its limitless coin tosses
to create pretty much anything else we
might imagine
including more of us and
new us as opposed to entire universes
require far fewer coin tosses
more specifically bodiless human brains
drifting alone through space
this so-called boltzmann brain named
after boltzmann's work
is part of a thought experiment that
looms over our current
theories of eternal maximum entropy it
seems
vanishingly unlikely that a cold empty
universe could create a human brain
replete with thoughts and artificial
sensations and memories
but it truly is one of the permutations
that the maximally disordered cosmos
can cycle through given enough time this
seemingly impossible permutation
could spontaneously appear
given an even longer amount of time it
could happen
over and over again
given the eternal end to our universe
statistically speaking
boltzmann brains are inevitable
and in fact in purely statistical terms
actual humans with the added
complications of physical bodies
existing in the actual universe when it
is nearly 14 billion years old
are vastly less likely than boltzmann
brains
in an empty universe that has been
cycling through random permutations
for hundreds of trillions of years
it follows that statistically our
thoughts and experiences are much more
likely to be an illusion of a fictitious
universe
conjured by non-corporeal boltzmann
brains
then they are true reflections of the
cosmos so close to its birth
of course physicists don't believe that
this is really the case
and the goal of modern cosmology is to
find a theory that does not threaten our
existence
and create a timeless eternity filled
with dreaming horus
if we really are here experiencing the
universe at nearly 14 billion years old
then the idea that the universe will
exist forever in timeless stasis
must be wrong we need a theory that will
produce a definitive end to space-time
before statistics has the opportunity to
create boltzmann brains
to outnumber us
there are possibilities being actively
pursued at the very bleeding edge of
theoretical physics a contracting
universe that leads to a big crunch and
rebirth
multi-dimensional string theory brain
collisions wiping us out
the search continues in hope
and so saint augustine could not have
known how right he was
when he wrote that time evades
definition
arthur eddington could describe the
arrow of time but he couldn't
truly comprehend it boltzmann for all
his troubled brilliance
only created a statistical demon that
continues to threaten
our reality and even today modern
physicists have no definitive
explanation
for the beginning or end of time which
raises
the grim thought perhaps all of these
influential minds
were really no more than that minds
floating aimlessly through space
dreaming of a universe they could almost
understand
and yet more likely perhaps our own
memory
of these scholars is a fiction concocted
by our single boltzmann brain
drifting in an eternal timeless universe
or perhaps sometime sooner theoretical
physics will find the answers we seek
for the sake of our reality we can only
hope
that it does
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like and
subscribe and leave a comment to tell us
what you think
and we'll see you next time
you